I was probably like 11 maybe 10 11 12
but my brother got his first BB gun and
our parents went out left us alone at
home with the BB gun so we lived right
in the Paxton Massachusetts right in the
Town Square so we're trying to shoot the
liquor store sign from across the street
because we're right there
and our parents are getting close to
getting home we're on the roof
but my brother has eight pumps in it and
he just does this to shoot the last
bullet and it hit a lady's driver's side
window and it just felt like a waterfall
and she locked up her brakes and I
remember us thinking we might have
killed someone at that age just sitting
turned on the TV like one day at a time
is on and we're trembling and trying to
keep everybody act cool yeah
yeah this is what you did before the
internet everybody this is why video
games and the internet are a good thing